downing street the very heart of boris
johnson's government
is in turmoil among a stream of damaging
leaks and revelations in recent days
the question of exactly how the
renovations of johnson's downing street
apartment were paid for
have been front page news it's been
alleged that johnson first tried to get
wealthy supporters to pay for the work
then that his political party loaned him
the money if so
that should have been made public prime
minister the electoral commission
is now involved and at the weekly
session of prime minister's questions
the opposition labour party smelled
blood who
initially and prime minister initially
is the key word here who initially
paid for the redecoration of his downing
street flat
prime minister mr speaker i think i've
answered this question
uh several times now and and the answer
the answer is that i have covered
the cost i have met the uh requirements
that i've
been obliged to meet in full what do we
get from this prime minister and this
conservative government
dodgy contracts jobs for their mates and
cash for access
and who's at the heart of it the prime
minister major sleaze
sitting there again and again
johnson wouldn't clarify who had paid
the initial invoice
repeating only that he personally had
covered the costs
regional and local elections are just a
week away and opinion polling
suggests the controversies are starting
to affect voter sentiment
again you're getting a pattern where at
some point
his credibility as prime minister will
evaporate
and you people got gotta ask do we want
somebody of that kind of
abject moral character as prime minister
at the core of this crisis is a bitter
dispute between boris johnson and this
man
his former closest advisor dominic
cummings
downing street accused cummings of being
the source of many of the recent
damaging leaks
cummings strongly rebutted that
publishing an explosive blog
which concluded that his former boss
fell far below
the required standards of competence and
integrity
boris johnson owes much of his political
success
to a remarkable teflon-like quality the
ability to survive controversies which
would have brought
down other lesser contemporary
politicians
it's almost as if different rules apply
to this prime minister
but that doesn't mean that the rules
don't exist and
in this electoral commission there is a
watchdog prepared to apply them
paul brennan al jazeera westminster